good afternoon everyone this is a it's
five o'clock in New York good afternoon
wherever you are it's a pleasure for me
to talk about the role of protective
jeans and exceptional longevity in
humans and i do want to mention that you
can submit questions during my talk and
i'll be happy to look at those questions
and uh and answer them eventually so the
first slide that i want to show you is
is crucial to understand the next 30
minutes or so because it shows the
relationship between death and age for
variety of disease and your people are
interested in variety of disease or
specializing in in specific diseases and
you see here that a age is a major risk
factor for those disease and it goes up
in a logarithmic fashion right the Y X
is a logarithmic so you and you go a
from a in either heart disease or cancer
or diabetes or I'll summer when you go
from the ages of 20 30 to the age of 80
the mortality increases from ten 2000
folds a while for example cholesterol is
a risk factor for heart disease but it's
a three-fold roots aging is really a
major is and from where we stand in the
biology of aging we are saying look a
unless you delay aging you cannot really
make an impact of the on diseases the
best that you can hope for is that to
switch one disease for another so we've
been really great at a preventing
cardiovascular disease but this is a
local treatment with stand and bypass
and what happens to those patients who
are now surviving heart disease will
they're getting within two years cancer
Alzheimer's diabetes because we never
delayed the aging we just delayed
delayed a specific disease and this is
the background for the research that I'm
going to talk about now if this was a
live coverage if I was speaking to you I
would ask you the question and it would
be interesting to see response I know
what your response would be I'm asking
you do we human age of different rates
do you know somebody who's 50 years old
it looks more like he's 40 do you know
somebody who's 50 years old it looks
like they're there are 60 and I tell you
most of you are saying probably yes we
intuitively know that we human age of
different rates and yet nobody has asked
really so what is the difference that
some people are aging faster than the
others and how can we use it in order to
delay aging and that explains why I'm
going to spend a significant amount of
time or talking about centenarians
because their aging has been delayed the
most so if you take those two things
together the fact that aging is a major
risk for all diseases that end that we
human age of different rates I want to
say again if one recovers from
cardiovascular disease and he had the
cardiovascular disease it early rate he
might next get diabetes in younger age
also so it's not only the age
relationship to disease is what happens
if you can treat one disease and let get
yet another and i have to tell you my
fear i'm doing everything to prevent
cardiovascular disease i'm i'm just
thinking that i'm going straight into
Alzheimer and I don't like this thought
a so I want to make a one point that we
know from centenarians studies from my
study and unfortunately too few other
studies but this is from pearl studies
New England sent an errand study the
chose really that the longer we have
lived okay the healthier ap
we'll have been and what you see here is
correlation between a h8 the appearance
of age-related diseases and the lifespan
of people and the different lines that
you are seeing are lines of people who
are either nineteen ninety-five hundred
hundred and 510 and over in other words
the the longer the farther the the line
to the right the longer they lived and
then there are four associations that
I'm not going to take you through each
one of them for association that shows
that whether it's for cardiovascular
disease all disease a cognitive function
the longer you leave the later you get
the disease so there is a relationship
between the age of death and the onset
of the disease so so if you if you if
you're going to live long you're going
to get the disease much later now let me
make a little bit a point about about
the challenges that we have and I drew
here just a cartoon and the Y X shows
youthfulness the scale of youthfulness
with age and basically chose that
youthfulness decline with age and and we
know those specific examples such as a
decline in growth hormone with age or
decline in sex hormone with age both
testosterone in men and estrogen are
declining with age and in the middle you
see many black lines and they represent
each of our theories of what happens how
things are declining with age and and
this is the challenges when we think of
all those lines that are are coming here
some of them are probably a causing
Aging in in maybe variety of way some of
those things that we measure and change
with aging maybe they have a change in
aging but they're not going to kill us
in this maximum lifespan that we have of
maybe hundred or somewhere between 100
and 120 years so there are good
biomarkers maybe but they're not the
causes of why we die
so this is ok but what takes a lot of
effort for us is that some of the
mechanisms that we are seeing we're
monitoring with aging our protective
mechanism of Beijing because just like
when we have infection we have an
inflammatory response when we have the
breakdown of aging there's a lot lots of
ways for our body to repair itself and
of course if something that we monitor
is a protective mechanism we don't know
what want to take it back to the
youthful level because it protects us so
how do we know what's protecting what's
adaptive what stressor what's a modifier
with aging and and in order to
demonstrate how severe is this challenge
for us I want to take you through the
next few slides and in the next slide
i'm going to show you what happens when
we age to the environment of the body
okay what happens when we age we get
more senescent cells those are cells
that have divided they're not going to
divide anymore but what happens with
them they are different biological and
by the way a lot of our cells are going
to be senescence cells and I'm showing
you a data not to really go through a
slide but just to impress you that you
see lots of panels here and you see that
they are in blue or in yellow the blue
represent secretory panel of pre
senescent cells so they are the normal
cells and the yellow represent a panel
of senescence cell and basically what it
shows you as you go from left to right
all those cytokines that are secreted
from senescent cells such as
interleukin-6 tnf-alpha lots of
cytokines so what they're doing is
they're changing the intrinsic
environment of the body now you have a
different interaction than when you were
young and why is it important to know
that's the only point I'm going to make
here why is it important well
let me give you i'm doing a provocation
on purpose let me let's talk about
estrogen because estrogen was thought to
be you know the major aging hormone
causes the decline in estrogen causes
women to age and if we could just stop
it those women will be totally young
again okay so will modulate it and will
stop aging and this study has been done
this is the women health initiative
studies and there are few things with
this with this study that are
problematic the way they were design at
least problematic from a from people who
are also biology's first of all you're
replacing only one hormone when we know
that with aging there's lots of changes
in hormone and other other you know the
intrinsic environment and other things
so why is it only replacing estrogen why
not replace the growth hormone you know
it's a very unit dimensional test the
second problem he is that I just told
you that the environment the intrinsic
environment of the body is different
when you are 70 then when you are 20 and
you don't know what is the interaction
what is the interaction between estrogen
and cytokines okay so that's a problem
too and third there is an assumption
okay that the fact that estrogen is
lower it's it it is it is because
something is wrong but not because it's
actually part of other potential
protection maybe estrogen higher
estrogen is harmful and that's why
estrogen is declining so the women
health initiative has done the study
they replaced estrogen there are some
good effects like the skin you know the
skin was much better but it was stopped
because of many bad effects including
cardiovascular disease breast cancer and
cognitive decline so in fact from an
aging perspective then a estrogen was it
was a pro aging hormone not an
anti-aging a hormone it just suggesting
how difficult it is to have the instinct
of you just going to replace with
something it's also is important for the
next sentence that I think is the most
important for you to understand there is
no doubt that hormones like estrogen or
hormones like testosterone are useful
hormones but their youthful hormones on
young body that doesn't mean that they
are youthful in old body and those
examples are showing you why in modern
biology and genetics we are choosing to
take other paths in order to determine
what is truly useful and when what is
not so let me go in and talk a little
bit about the genetic of of human
longevity and I I would like to
introduce my my study and show some of
the of the results but I'll also talk
about the state of the art as I said not
too many studies are out there but only
one out of ten thousand individual is
100 years old so this is a very rare
phenotype it's more rare than cystic
fibrosis so we recruited almost 600
patients that had to be healthy at age
95 they ever they spend from 95 212
which was our oldest a and basically we
were taking people who consider
themselves healthy at age 95 as we and
other have accumulated those kind of
unique a rare individual we found that
there is a remarkable family history
with exceptional longevity in other
words the chances of their siblings and
parents and everybody else to have
longevity was was many fold increase up
to 20-fold increase so it wasn't as
small effect and by the way the
heritability of aging otherwise is not
so strong so it gets stronger only in
those extreme age so with this we could
form two hypotheses one I hypothesis is
you know what we know all those
genotypes that are associated with a
variety of age-related disease you know
those guys have the perfect genome okay
that's why
they don't get the disease they just
don't have snips for aging diseases and
I'll tell you already that we know that
that's not so they are actually have as
many genotypes for aging research for
aging and diseases and so the other
hypotheses is that they have protective
genes that assures their longevity and
we have much more support for this
concert so let me introduce you to the
centenarians very briefly what you see
here is four siblings taken when the
woman who stands on the left was 104
those are four people were born between
1910 and 19 20 22 parents and those are
the only kids all those four kids is the
only kids that they had and what's
unique with those four kids all of them
past the age of 102 the woman standing
on the Left died at 110 and the two
brothers are still alive one of them is
107 almost 108 works every day and the
other is not in as good shape but he's a
hundred and five years old I mean what
are the chances that you have people
with such an exceptional longevity also
interesting to note that we have data
from the CDC for years that the last two
years of medical cost is third in
centenarians that in people who are
dying between 60 and 70 so it reflects
the fact that they were healthy for a
long time and in fact there is a
compression of morbidity so they died
actually after many many fewer years of
diseases you might say but hey you know
so maybe there maybe it's in the family
and maybe it's rare and maybe there's
genetic component but maybe it's all the
environment so I want to take care of
that for a second and show you
highlights of paper that we published a
couple of years ago so if you wonder
almost half of our patients are
overweight or obese so it's not that
they've done something special about
food or calorically restricted them not
not
population a smoking sixty percent of
the men thirty percent of the women
smoked for many years many pegs a
alcohol daily not enough physical
activity well we're talking about even
walking or or biking or household less
than half we're doing anything so it's
not that they're great athletes or
something something like that for those
of you are vegetarians I'm really sorry
to tell you not many vegetarians are in
a hundred years old group and by the way
those are we we had another group of
comparison and they were sorry i I'll
figure out to do it a little better but
in another comparison group they were
either worse or the same for their
cohort so in other words it's not the
day interacted with the environment
which leaves again the possibility that
they have genes that are different well
so i told you that i have a bunch of
centenarians and we are looking at them
but hey what's the problem with this
study the the problem is i didn't tell
you what control group we have an H it's
hard to get a control group because
their friends have died basically 50
years ago life expectancy for many of
them when they were born was forty years
so okay so there so what's the
appropriate control and what we've done
here we've done something a unique we
recruited their offspring and the
importance of their offspring that they
are enriched with the longevity genotype
and phenotype there are lots of other
issues here for why and how we use the
offspring but one important point is
that a we can match the offspring by age
and gender and so we have offspring that
are match to h h match control without
longevity in their family so the ones
who are unrelated to the centenarians
and are still young and are unlikely to
be 100 is the control group and we see
the genetics compared to the
centenarians themselves now one of the
problems with genetic research that is a
big challenge is that
you just walk in the streets of you know
Los Angeles or New York and look for a
candidates you'll get diversity of the
population this diversity is immediately
a nightmare in a genetic point of view
so the best the best group in the world
probably to have a successful genetic
contribution that affected health are
probably the Icelandic the Icelandic
where five Vikings and for Irish women
and everybody there is is there are
brothers or cousins so so if somebody
has disease within this population or
not it's much easier to identify the
genetic component of that for that
reason we're using Ashkenazi Jews those
are white European a genomes that have a
reason for for lots of lots of history a
lot of bed history too but they're
considered homogeneous more than just
taking the white population alone and
just to show you that we're kind of a on
the way and we're doing a study that is
reasonable is that during the
recruitment it was already clear that
the offspring of centenarians were
healthier than control so the offspring
of Center in blue have less hypertension
let's diabetes mellitus as myocardial
infarction and less stroke but I want to
bring him the centenarians themselves
here in green because the centenarians
were 30 years older than the control
group have barely the same prevalence of
hypertension much less diabetes and
about the same prevalence of my project
infarction and stroke so it shows you
that their aging has been basically
delayed by 30 years if just to continue
this point to larger scale study their
other support that the age of parent is
affecting the onset of age-related
disease in other words if you had old
parents you've got the disease later and
one is from the diabetes prevention
trial and the diabetes prevention trial
it took people at risk of diabetes and
gave them either metformin or lifestyle
as an intervention that they were both
successful metformin decrease a diabetes
by thirty-eight percent and I asked the
people in the beep DPP if the age of one
of the the father or the mother had any
effect on the onset of diabetes in this
trial and the example here is of the or
is the paternal side the same is true of
it for the maternal side and you see
three graphs that are reflecting models
so it's not really important you can
follow the red line just to be or the
blue line just for simplicity and it
shows you that if you have one parent
that lived over the age of 80 whether it
was father and mother as I said before
you're the thirty percent reduction in
the onset of diabetes in other words
choosing your parents right having an
old parent that survived over the 80 was
as effective as taking metformin when
you had pre-diabetes the same thing is
true to study that I was involved with
on people that were recruited from the
community and we asked if they had one
parent over the age of 85 did it affect
the onset of Alzheimer and as you see
here a people who had one parent over
the age of 85 that's the the upper group
had a delay of Alzheimer or cognitive
decline in about thirty percent so you
have to understand it's not only that
centenarians are unique but any a age
any advanced age of the parent has an
impact on the age where their kids are
getting this disease
so how do we go and making it genetic
discoveries from this study well a you
know they're a they're a there's an
opportunity here that doesn't exist in
other thing and that is that a that a we
have the ajaxes okay and the age axis is
totally selected in other words a a what
people people died at the average age of
18 in the United States half of the
people died so if we if we're populating
with people or 85 90 95 hundred we're
selecting them for longevity if we're
selecting them for longevity then if we
get a pattern like that where a genotype
start disappearing and it's very
meritage on with its killing them but if
we have a genotype that is a increasing
and its high at age 100 we would say you
know what they are they have protective
jeans and and they are leaving a and and
this is maybe the reason that's on Java
tee jeans and that's the reason why
they're in rich in centenarians and some
of them are not changing there are
several genotypes that I want to talk
about one genotypes is called foxo3a and
the interesting thing about the foxo3a
genotype is that it was validated by at
least eight groups whether it's the most
validated genotype and validation is
really difficult in a studies eh eh
although it's validated it's the less
understood because there's nothing else
that comes out on why it's important
there there's no changes in under
intermediate genotype the the genes the
genotypes that that could be a
functional significant we don't find
them so it's it's kind of an interesting
observation but we don't know yet what
to make of it on the other hand there
are many other genotypes that have been
discovered and validated before and I'll
go from the lower to the upper but
because all of them
are are published I'll just say a line
about each one of them and we'll start
in the lower one that goes from almost
zero percent to two percent in
centenarians and this is a functional
mutation in IGF receptor interestingly
in nature the dwarf live longer the
ponies live longer than the horse the
the Delta small dogs live longer than
the large dogs and so there is something
that is conserved also in animals in
evolution and we have those a small
group of centenarians but have this
functional mutation and we think it
helped them get to this age the two
above that that go from about ten
percent to about twenty percent are two
genotypes lipid genotypes one is Apple C
3 and 1 or 1 is CTP both of them are
carrying a phenotype a lipid phenotype
so lipid are important modulator of
longevity mainly HDL is the marker for
their effect and the higher 21 is a
thyroid a TSH TSH receptor of normality
centenarians have higher TSH they their
their children have higher TSH so it's a
heritable TSH they have there are not
hypothyroid but they have lower t3 and
t4 and the major point here is when you
have th the sides and hands don't treat
it because maybe it allowed them to get
there and the other is that the
connecting adiponectin is a is a feather
I've hormone it has very good effect and
adiponectin level is very high in
centenarians and a maybe each one of
them can contribute to longevity
significantly I I want to make one point
when we look at those genotypes we want
them to be protective against aging you
know we hope they delay aging maybe they
delay several age-related disease maybe
even they delay a 1-h disease but the
CTP genotype is very important because
it demonstrates that ctp
or these lipid levels are not only
important for cardiovascular disease but
they're also important for cognitive
function and what you see here is a
study that shows that if you had the two
alleles for the ctp genotype that are in
red a you would have a seventy percent
decline in dementia free survival and
alzheimer free survival so they seem to
be very protective for cognitive a
function so just to make the point that
that you need to show effect on many
age-related disease in order to see that
it really delays aging another thing
that is important with the CTP is that
there is a drug company that is
developing CTP inhibit or and just to
make the point and they publish the
initial results are in phase 3 trial but
the point here is that from finding
genetic studies to getting drugs is
sometimes not long and of course this
drug has to be tried and see if it
delays aging or delays the diseases but
it's very important to realize that
that's important in so you know how can
we discover mechanism of action or
longevity genes well we can do
functional tests which we have done we
can look at the interventional test for
example is the IGF receptor we found we
could do functional test if the lipid
shows that we can do intermediate
phenotype we can see the HDL the LDL the
lipoprotein particle size or we can
associate with outcomes but there is
another thing that we can do that is is
is kind of unique to what we've been
doing and I'll exemplify it very shortly
in the next few slide and this is how it
goes clato is one of those killing genes
okay in fact in our population like in
other population the people have clato
disappear by age of 85 we have half of
the people that we had when we took took
a group of people in 60 so we think it's
killing people so we are assuming that
the 804 there'll be higher
anyone with a cluttered genotype when in
fact we find that that 800 they have
almost the same amount of clutter
genotype almost the same prevalence as
as the air as in in the young one so
what is it how is this genotype looks
like it's an aging an aging genotype and
then it looks like it's a longevity
genotype well after lots of sleepless
night we realize that if you're if
you're the rare guy that's going to be
hundred years old and you have a
protective genotype you can harbor maybe
a variety of genotypes that are bad for
you except that you're not you're not
going to care for them because you're
protected so in fact at age 100 we would
expect and that's as I told you we found
many of us found that we find all those
other genotypes that are bad for you and
but the most important thing is that we
can use this u-shaped curve in order to
look at mechanism and I'll jump through
the next slide just to get to this
example and this is example of LP little
a LP lays another lipoprotein that's
associated with cardiovascular death and
it drops in our population until age 80
you lose 23 you know half of the
genotype but at age 100 there is a lot
of it and so what we do we do a gene to
Jeannie interaction where we take all
the people with a bed LPL rare genotype
and we look at every longevity genotype
and when we got to see TP this is the
example that I'm carrying you through
when we got to see TP we got the
following people who didn't have the
good CTP genotype versus the people who
got who had the good CTP genotype so
that people who had the good CTP
genotype in green accounted for the
majority of people in that could Harbor
LP LA in other words they're alive
because they have LP lay it because
because they have CTP genotype and
actually in working their study have
shown that in a preliminary way also
lastly I want to make few points about
how the environment interacts with jeans
because certainly the environment has a
lot to do with aging and and so I'll
give you two example one is a through
methylation and the important thing to
know is that methylation sorry I'm doing
those same mistakes again the important
thing to know that a methylation is a
way to control gene expression and when
we used to talk about edge in epigenetic
we thought you know it happens early and
it's done but what we're discovering is
that epigenetic modulation happens in
almost every tissue throughout life and
what we're seeing here divided by the
black line in the middle on the right we
see people who are 65 years old on the
left people are 95 years old and this is
a very high throughput essay that looks
at methylation side throughout the
genome like three million methylation
sites throughout the genome in in places
where we think are important they may be
important for physiology and you see
that it's very different the left and
the right side are very different on the
right side the upper panel is yellow and
on the right side the 65 years old is
quite red by the way there are 75 and 85
there that are kind of in the middle but
you see how we can go throughout it it
becomes red in 95 and then yellow in
control etc etc in other words there is
a lot of epigenetic modulation that's
going on that in part to have a sequence
a consequence and we'll figure out the
consequence of that not so easy a but
but that's it any important direction
and it has a lot to do with aging and
how we are protected against aging the
second epigenetic mechanism is by micro
RNA so what you see in the panel is
centenarians on the right side under the
yellow bar and controls on the left
right under the red bar and you see
variety of micro RNA and under the
centenarians you see those red lines
those are a centenarians will have very
high expression of micro RNAs micro RNA
usually go down with aging but
centenarians have micro RNA that seems
to be other represented or over
expressed and lots of them have a major
role in a biological processes so I'm
going to stop here in micro RNA but the
last two slides just meant to tell you
that there's a lot of epigenetic things
that are going aging and in contributes
immensely to the aging phenotype so I
want to get this get to the
question-and-answer period and summarize
that a it's important to realize in my
message here that if you can prevent
aging you may prevent its diseases the
biology of aging is exciting it's a it's
unexpected a it shows you what happens
when all the studies we're doing in
animals are in young animals a and and
you get a little bit different view then
when you wait for those animals to be
all because the environment is old but
if we could do anything with this
biology of aging we can probably make
progress in diseases I showed you
example that research to the biology and
genetic of aging is bearing fruits or
bearing medications and that we can
actually understand genetic mechanisms I
gave you an example of how by
interaction between genes between those
u-shape genotypes and longevity
genotypes we can find how longevity gene
it protects against a certain aging gene
so if we have a longevity gene that
protects against many genes we can maybe
develop one drug to affect all those
diseases and we don't need more a
also I made it a point that the
interaction between the environment and
genes work in an epigenetic a mechanism
i gave you two example you know very
prominent example you know in the media
is resveratrol the wine extract that
observation that came from the biology
of aging that resveratrol extends life
and and there's another pharmaceutical
company that has some patterns to
activate the pathways that are involved
in in resveratrol but the mechanism here
is also epigenetics is through histone
deacetylation so those are the major
point i I wanted to make and I also you
know want to want you to understand and
I showed you the relationship between
age of death and onset of disease there
there's more evidence that that if you
can get to higher age you're going to
contract morbidity in other words people
will be healthier for longer and they'll
die much sooner after the onset of the
diseases then if they had to carry those
diseases at early age for many years so
a what we want is not to live longer we
want to have a good quality of life so
are our goals in all those all this
research in the biology of Aging in
genetic of aging is to come up with some
drugs that can be tested to see if they
prevent the chronic debilitating a
related disease of Aging and this
longevity longer life is more of a side
effect of the loop drugs and we'll have
to apologize but we want to come up from
a the point of view that weird we're
trying to prevent age-related diseases a
this is my grandmother in law in her
100th birthday and she taught me a lot
about what I know about a longevity at
her 100th birthday she drank this was
very droll straight from
at the bottle she was dating than a man
but only those who could drive and she
complained that to find somebody that
could drive had she had to decrease the
age of date to 85 years old and they are
a little young for her and she died
without being sick any day in her life
and without taking any medications and
I'm kind of jealous on her achievement
so let me stop now and and see if I can
have any a question and I'll be happy to
answer them
you
I'm not seeing any questions yet okay I
see some question so the first the first
question is a how have you excluded
family dietary habits and environment
and I think maybe it was written before
I started talking about it is it's a
good question but as I said our
population a another population of
centenarians when you're trying to find
if they were distinct there are not
distinct in fact what's really funny is
that sometimes they they just say that a
a you know we ate chicken fat all our
lives they give the examples of what
they think is associated longevity that
we will necessary to tell our patient to
do so there's no there's no doubt that
the environment is important and if you
want to get to behind the age of 80 you
have to do what you need to do to deal
with the environment but this is not the
case for our centenarians and that's why
they are so interesting second question
does the are typical TSH level a we use
a reduced risk of thyroid disease in
centenarians and I cannot say that I
know that our Center errands have been
healthy and a very few of them had
thyroid disease but I cannot say that
the TSH level it sells itself a thyroid
disease okay another interesting
question which I expected is about
telomeres and we did measure till mr.
centenarians and their telomeres are are
longer than the telomeres of 85 year old
without longevity in their family okay
they are significantly longer but what
does it mean that's the question what
does it mean
e are they healthy and that's why
they're telomere longer or is the
telomere have to do anything with our
age I don't want to go to a big
controversy but I would just tell you
that even if you knock down the
telomeres in in Nice they don't age more
rapidly a you need to do a lot of
manipulation and a lot of generation in
order to start getting sperms with low
low low telomeres that will affect a
will affect them but the telomere
question whether it's cause an effect is
still a big question the telomeres have
the ability to modulate a themselves a
period of stress decrease telomere
length period of recovery christy lemire
length it's very it's very complex I
would say it could be a marker for
longevity but it doesn't mean it's a
cause for longevity next question is
there any particular region of
chromosome from which this micro RNA
either express or do this a map back to
I cannot see the next line I'm sorry a a
complicated those micro RNA a you know I
think the answer because this is a
specific question you could watch
potentially you can look at pubmed put
my name and Su Su h using y and and see
some of the preliminary data that we had
and you'll have an answer have any
apoptotic pathway studies being done in
centenarians to understand the
expression level a so i want to tell you
that we have a a lymphoblast of those
sentiments and we're doing lots of
stress response on those lymphoblastoid
lymphoblast are not prone to a pep talk
apoptosis and on a genetic level they
are several genotypes that are apoptotic
genotypes that are different between
centenarian control not in a very
significant way but this
certainly await something to look to
look at next question amen stopped a man
stopped smoking just two years ago he's
about 91 year old now and he still alive
could it be the presence of for some
reason I cannot go a down the line the
line here but a this woman who died at
110 years old she smoked for 95 years so
first of all if you smoke for 95 years
you do live a long life I can promise
that but the point is that she was
protected from the effect of of a of
cigarettes a what is it for a 91 year
old what what is smoking going to do I
don't know I need to know a little bit
more about it a next question a is the
rate of motor Genesis lowering
centenarians we don't know this answer
so telomere length can a can increase
are you saying that telomere length is
more of an effect of age and jeans
rather than again I'm sorry that I
cannot find a way to see the end of your
question a ya a telomere telomere length
a can can change positively it let me
make it clear telomere length on average
goes down with aging ok even in
longitudal study you take a man and
follow it five or ten years later
telomere length will decrease the
question is a does it lead to aging and
I think it probably doesn't lead to
aging a there there are diseases in
humans like primary pulmonary fibrosis
where there is no lung tissues left and
I think at that point the telomere is
playing a major role in the phenotype of
these disease that's not to say that
telomeres are leading
the aging a last question that I have is
is there any study of longevity genes
from other ethnic groups from comparison
yes absolutely it's very important we
actually are leading an international
effort to get sentence from all over the
world and let me give an example of the
complexity and I'll go back to the CTP
this genotype that I i put in a as an
example for many things so this specific
polymorphism on the CTP gene a does not
exist in Japanese okay but they have
another mutation in the CTP gene and
that is significantly different than
others so so it's a it's it's a it's
going to be a challenge to go from
population to population the major thing
to realize is that we're not interested
in a certain genotype the certain
genotype in certain population a leads
us to a mechanism okay so for example
with the CTP the people will see TP head
high HDL cholesterol high good
cholesterol for me this is what's
important now if you go to another
population and you take the same
genotype and they don't have higher HDL
it's because we're not built with one
from one general typing at a time we're
built from many general type that
they're in a certain background with
either have a phenotype or not have a
phenotype so it is important to see
everything about that and not to focus
on a specific snail and um I'm waiting
for a wait a minute to see if there's
any other a question am I
okay i think i think i want to thank i
think that those questions were
absolutely to the point i want to thank
you for listening and I hope I am I made
a case of why delaying aging can be
really good for for for everyone thanks
very much
you